so why do you say was why G was eating
yeah
slightly different in the sauces but I
why'd you I respect your tofu hey what's
going on everybody for first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones it's the show with hot questions
and even had her wings and today we're
joined by schoolboy kill the grade is
he's a five-time Grammy nominated
platinum selling artist every album he
drops as a marquee event in hip hop and
his most recent release crash talk is no
different schoolboy q welcome to the
show at uh how are you a spicy food D
creamy I love spicy food I prefer spicy
food all the time but you know the one
they prepped me before this they made it
seem like this was like a normal spicy
so I'm a little nervous right now in
your head a little bit yeah yeah you
[Music]
[Music]
Lestat
[Music]
so back in 2016 you famously trolled
fans by releasing a version of the blank
face album art with the glue crying
Jordan me matte afternoon and then even
your most recent video for nom nom juice
it has these deep cut internet
references like Elon Musk hitting the
joint on the Joe Rogan podcast I use the
internet for funny things a lot of
people grieve on the internet and a lot
of people like you know look for sad
things and try to do motivational things
on an Internet and I'm just not really
here for that like I did with all that
in real life so but I most part I'm just
looking for funny stuff dude it's not
funny I'm just follow right by and then
what about when you drop a project like
do you care what people are saying about
it online or do you block out the
Twitter chat I don't I don't yeah I
don't check comments because it's always
bad you get good you get good comments
obviously yeah you get a more good than
bad but for some reason you only focus
on the bad ones those are the ones who
remember yeah exactly so yeah I'm not
here for slander know that you can call
on that sauce BAE yeah you like that one
yeah yeah so like me
mr. price hot sighs I understand it
you've been working on your golf game
almost daily falling in love with the
sport on accident taking a bet from a
friend who said you couldn't hit a
birdie mm-hmm what would you say has
been your crowning golf achievement so
far but for the most part II of playing
golf got me out of like depression or
stuff because like sometimes you can be
depressed don't know you depress because
you're just going through the motions of
life I mean I was the guy that I didn't
like to take pictures with fans and
stuff I mean I would do it but for the
most part it was like attitude or I was
just like bottom I felt like I always
walk everywhere I go my hoodie on and my
hair down just in a dark space where you
just are just not good it's not healthy
to raise kids that way and last year I
couldn't found off my ideas start
flowing better tomorrow my moves start
flowing better I became a better parent
I just smile a smile way more you know I
stopped being just as depressed want to
stay in the house hide all day and then
like hip-hop golf has a lingo and an
etiquette that's all its own so what I
want to do is hit you with some golf
slang and if you know what it means
maybe you can explain it to the people
watching and if you don't know what it
means maybe just take a guess okay all
right yeah I'm be honest most mom isn't
really into all that but um I may know
something yeah maybe fixham see baby
let's see have you ever heard of a fried
egg
oh yeah Friday that's one it's in the
bunker and uh the ball is like
surrounded in this little island the
same kind of ding ding ding ding what's
a duffer or a hacker ah ha ha me me baby
that duffel I know cuz I have a bad
problem of I used to play baseball you
be really good at baseball so I have a
bad habit when I play golf
I lean back a lot what about a chili dip
have you ever heard of a chili dip yeah
Mandy some real white [ __ ] that
invented this you know none of that
really do I think it's like when you
take out some grass before you hit the
ball that's pretty much it dip on it
oh yeah there's like a dub do you know
what cabbages no I smoked a B we smoked
all a lot of that [ __ ] on the corner Oh
so up next Shaquanda is hot peppers
Wanda's our little ghetto ass talk about
[Music]
it so far so good so you get a lot of
love in the rap community not only
because of the artistry and realness
that you bring to the music but also for
being one of the funniest guys behind
the scenes yeah and then you had some
hilarious segments with Pete Holmes back
when he had it he remembered those
moments very fondly when he was on hot
ones but he did make the point that
rappers are always burdened with this
having to be cool
all the time rappers take away their
funny side by trying to be a rapper like
you see rappers like the whole thing is
just like a thing is like like a rapper
kid like a bunch of chains like yeah you
know so the camera girl and they go
right into mode oh you see this little
lame ass [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
ain't getting no money but like
everybody but you know that's just
represent thing and not being a self I'm
more so being myself I know a lot of
rappers are funny it just won't be they
sell
[Music]
now this should easy call no problem
easy oh good
so before the Billboard hits in the
platinum records and of the II had
dreams of being a scholarship athlete
and to this day still follow things like
the UFC and college basketball very
closely love it UFC boxing in college
basketball I love it and then two-time
MVP Mike Trout for a while man of the
year was his walk-up song yeah and you
know I'm a die-hard angel thing yeah did
you get a chance to meet him when you
threw out the first pitch of that man
I'm mad dough I wanted to see him meet
him you know I mean but didn't work out
do you have a suggestion for the new
walk-up song that he should do gotta go
no no dude you gotta turn up to look
cool happen now that jacket uh yeah but
that might be a little too much point
there come on get us [ __ ] yeah you
gotta come on some bows man is it still
[ __ ] the Dodgers [ __ ] the Dodgers for
show [ __ ] the Dodger everybody I know is
Dodger fans I grew up in LA LA you know
what I mean so everybody I know is
Dodger fans in his life they don't let
you breathe like soon as they find out
you an angel fan is like what he'll be
here to my whole life hey weak ass they
get to the championship they're good
every year don't do [ __ ] still ain't won
since I was [ __ ] born what 86 I was
born in 86
[ __ ] 20 years old time other
Dodgers this down to that [ __ ] you
never saw anything
you never saw nothing like it you [ __ ]
be to hit me up maybe about comments on
it something like Bronco nobody got time
for that
Dodgers [ __ ] [ __ ] the Dodgers I know
that you've been to some PGA Tour events
do you have an opinion on these fans
that scream things like Baba Booey or
mashed potatoes I'm worried I wanted to
dig those framing issues toady feet out
we was playing I was my partner in
Genesis yeah open and now I'm I just
kept saying trippy notice my own thing
when I had a good shot at strip you know
you know I mean he said it into a master
staying use like plenty such as such or
someone chip for something he's like
yeah and I just tripped it in hello yeah
you know I'm rubbing off on you guys
yeah I mean so yeah I'll [ __ ] with it
I'll [ __ ] with the hecklers the [ __ ]
long as they don't do it in the middle
of your backswing but right after you
hit it yeah yeah fair game
I love that most communities we're gonna
spice that in this [ __ ] they
talk about assault crying [ __ ] it's
coming I'll remember you said this so
typically on winged five we do this
thing called explain that grin but it
makes no sense for you because you have
this habit of completely washing and
deleting all the pictures off your
Instagram from time to time so we're
gonna call an audible and take it back
to a 2014 interview you did with power
106 where you described yourself as a
boring person who sits around playing
video games and one of our favorite
things to talk about on hot ones is
celebrity gamers and whether or not they
talk they trash talk teenagers over the
headset oh yeah I'm going here do you
remember the last time you snapped on
the PlayStation Network every day
there's no do I remember I did it today
yesterday day before yesterday let me
tell you this I did it tomorrow to your
own saying I do it every day it's you
bet nice if once I see your mic pop up
on the side hey you [ __ ] ass [ __ ] hey
what you talk about as soon as it's over
I'm gonna write you know did you ever
get recognized yeah I hear people
thrilled because my name is schoolboy q
or my gang but it spells like way
different but you can kind of tell it's
spelled schoolboy q lot of people like
schoolboy q sucks too like who a name
itself after schoolboy q you try but
he's washed up who who listens
I once heard a story about lil yachty
and twenty-one savage plain NBA 2k for
twelve thousand dollars a game have you
dabbled in the world of high-stakes game
hannes especially I'm doing bench only
doing that [ __ ] Instagram right have you
picked a side in the great fortnight vs.
apex Legends to be picks yeah for
tonight was dope when it first came out
I was [ __ ] with it I was going in but
then I started making it weak kid
friendly you know I mean like once the
game gets so big they have no choice but
to cater to the weaker side of it
because not too many people are good you
know it's a small percentage of people
that are good versus people I just plan
so as a right now apex is [ __ ] on
fortnight but apex is growing just
rapidly crazy crazy it's gonna be just
as big as fortnight and they gonna have
to cater to a bunch of weak guys little
ass punk ass kids and I'm gonna be right
back a cold faithful call of duty it's
gonna be the same it's always always
their faithful
by age so you've said that you're not
into a nerdy spaceship rap or pokemon
bar is a purist who thinks that your
lyrics should reflect your life and then
of course a challenge of that as
eventually as a rapper you'll become a
dad who plays golf and then Shops at
Whole Foods do you ever think about that
like are you interested in how MCS like
jay-z or NAS have had to find ways to
rap about post success life in a
compelling way oh yeah I did pokey man
[ __ ] dog can't stand that old rapping as
[ __ ] dog
rapping super fast and Arnold is like
I'm gonna always give you everything now
pal I'm gonna have a rap something for
my white folks around something for my
gentle [ __ ] I might have something
for my radio people man something for
everybody brothers as an artist I think
that's what you're supposed to do you
don't suppose just cater to one fanbase
you normally I'll be a fool to just sit
there and make a bunch of songs like
blessed orange on mirror you know so I
love the balance of music and of it so I
really don't care about all that other
shape and then another way that you're
unique is that you don't just flood the
music marketplace with songs you seem to
come out with these fully crafted albums
do you have an idea of the schoolboy q
story like is that already plotted out
or is every album every project like a
fresh start
um I had a whole thing mapped out it
worked out good up until the second I
hope so the first two albums were
playing down I'm gonna do this my name
is hazel mad it's gonna be did after
that it was just like life hit you
different things happen your mood
changes my whole thing now with music is
making sure this album don't sound like
that out that's why I always do like two
albums before I actually finalize album
and they're always pretty trashed you
know to me I think it's the one I get on
Twitter or some oh I'm coming so you're
right that was the first album but to go
back go through it I'll cover so that
was the second album did I'll finally
figure it out can you offer gonna be
three two years like
angle a dismal look blue sheisty yeah
[Music]
I'm holding a lot I think I do
oh no no no no no okay it's happening No
[Music]
so you've been pretty open about some of
the struggles in your life that affected
your ability to be a good father but now
it's such an amazing thing to see the
relationship that you have with your
daughter joy you guys on the red carpet
together at the Grammys and the matching
girl power hoodies but I did see an
amazing video on your snapchat where she
called your rapping trash and she called
TDE trash
like I feel like if you're dealing with
that kind of savagery from your own kin
you can handle anything yeah I think I
get it from a mama you know her friends
come over here just hearing that bilasa
all day yeah they just popping [ __ ] and
since the kid my mom used to pop should
that mean that's why I'm with my
daughter too like I talk [ __ ] to her all
day and she talks you to me all day and
I wouldn't want you to no other way
you're gonna meet right don't ever tell
me I look nice walking out the house you
know what I mean never she's like ah you
look terrible you look stupid
all that tight-ass shirt like my dumb
daughter you know like I mean all that
love I need that love I thought
it's no gotta talk yah-hey right to [ __ ]
but I'll do some lifting foot off so I
know that you've chilled
I'm the bucket hat since its gone
mainstream but it's impossible to deny
your influence in the style trend your
roots in it what makes the bucket hat a
good go-to for huskier boys you've got a
fat ass face first part let's just let
that record reflect so you put on a
regular cap throw a regular camp
yo fat ass face gonna look fatter with
that little ass capo
so put a bugger at home I'm gonna play a
little game called who wore it better
and pull out some iconic bucket hat
moments in pop culture history and you
just tell me who rocks at them okay who
rocked it better on the golf course
Bill Murray or Kevin James me Bill
Murray who rocked it better on the red
carpet we have Justin Timberlake and
then Buckethead who's literally double a
bucket on his head Justin Timberlake and
then finally who worked better on stage
schoolboy q or Billy Eilish we always go
away too much me whoa is this the spice
you've been looking for
splicer
[ __ ] abuzz my got the gay [ __ ] up
I respect you thank you that means a lot
to me
I respect you
[Music]
so these decide was YG was eating yeah
slightly different in the sauces but I
watch you I respect you too
yeah one thing a real little but yeah
and you say here you in it come on ice
cream coming in ice cream coming in but
where are you going up so here at first
we feast we're obsessed with what our
guests eat so now seems like as good a
time as any to shout out your favorite
restaurant
the shabu shabu house central in
downtown Los Angeles
oh yeah well may you greatest of all
time don't you ever come to this
[ __ ] do rappers have their own
secret network of restaurant
reservations like if you land in New
York own up action some cool as I move
and then some rappers like wale and
Vince staples they've started Yelp
accounts where they're actually review
restaurants would that be something that
would ever interest you while they have
bids to weirdo ass [ __ ] they
came here to they both came here yeah
[ __ ] weirdos
[Music]
all right school boy this is the last
dab we call it the last dab because of
the tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to you crazy
you don't have to if you don't want to
that
hey have any of y'all tried this [ __ ]
it's an initiation for the crew you know
[Music]
that's too hot
that's good that's good
goddamn yeah I'm up I'm not like putting
extra solder [ __ ] or nothing
that [ __ ] is high yeah yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] the bomb I'm gonna [ __ ] if y'all
invested in it or what
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] up
we are not we're not and that's a great
segue for what's going down in wing Ted
okay
how like I just stare at me to see
what's about to happen
all right schoolboy q here we are at the
top of spice Mountain a hallowed ground
or only a few people have ever stood
before and now that you have these wings
these hot sauces running through you
bringing your blood to a boil it's time
to bring some of that Schoolboy Q
realness to the hot sauce lineup in
front of us today that's the bomb hot
Trinidad scorpion I can [ __ ] with them
cuz it's hot but it's not too crazy
right vibe but it's hot what about the
Hellfire Detroit that's good it's real
good the lowest calientes good
what about Shaquanda put the fake
project yeah this is but do you have a
favorite on the line up these two sauce
Bay and the Detroit Hellfire and look at
you schoolboy q starting at the handle
looking for the heat finding it and then
getting on top of it to clear the board
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you my friend
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life like I don't drunk so much
water and should you try to flip I'm
full as [ __ ] to like so my stomach is
like hurting from drinking and you get
up saying like I got you
I got an album out breath
[Music]
[Applause]
trash-talk all platforms home hi what's
up edibles and [ __ ] are you feel that
[ __ ] hot ones [ __ ] up heist welcome
hi what's up spice Lords og camera guy
bill here I'm ready to spit some fire
for you summer 2019 no scallion tastes a
stop yet I like to eat it with my
friends in the sunshine it is the best
putting my taste buds to the test the
heat really burns just like my skin eat
some more it's not a sin poured on top
of all your food people walking by
saying who's the king
go to keep this calm don't be a buffer
set is no scallion sauce in the summer
go to keep mr. calm
don't be a bummer what it is summer 2019
sauce of the summer los calientes in
prego now get the hell out of my seat
I'm sorry I'm sorry
[Music]
you